sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen das jahr
2022 ist in vielfacher hinsicht ein
krisenjahr der angriffskrieg russlands
gegen die ukraine inflation extrem
steigende energie und verbrauchskosten
und sorgen um die versorgungssicherheit
und all das trifft auf eine gesellschaft
und auf eine wirtschaft die sich noch
immer von den auswirkungen der korona
pandemie ja nicht erholen konnte damit
immer noch zu kämpfen hat und
gleichzeitig brennen wälder in ganz
europa belastet die hitze vor allem
ältere menschen trockenen flüsse aus und
all das folgen eines weiteren hitze und
dürre sommers und der fortschreitenden
klimakrise und jetzt rächt sich wir
spüren dass ganz extrem das viel zu
lange nur ungenügend energiesparen auf
der agenda gestanden hat dass der
naturverträgliche ausbau der
erneuerbaren energien und der stromnetze
verschoben wurde blockiert wurde diese
erblast kommt uns jetzt teuer zu stehen
für die bundesregierung haben in diesem
äußerst angespannten situation die
versorgungssicherheit und die hilfe für
die bevölkerung und das vor allem für
die menschen mit geringem einkommen
priorität und das im koalitionsausschuss
am vergangenen sonntag beschlossene
hilfspaket ist groß für mich als
verbraucherschutzministerin ist dabei
die kombination aus
strompreis bremse dem schutz vor
kündigungen der mieter und für strom und
gas sperren sowie natürlich dem paket
finanzielle entlastungen entscheidend
gewesen und deshalb halte ich das
erzielte ergebnis wirklich für gut
es stehe dazu sagen dass damit natürlich
nicht alle belastungen der
verbraucherinnen und verbraucher
ausgeglichen werden können das ist
schlicht nicht möglich
aber wir federn die härten ab und wir
helfen vor allem dort wo es am
dringlichsten ist
aus sicht des verbraucherschutzes ist
natürlich ebenso essentiell dass die
versorgungssicherheit in der
gegenwärtigen situation
gewährleistet ist und ich habe deshalb
gesagt dass wir das ergebnis des
stresstestes des
bundeswirtschaftsministeriums zur
versorgungssicherheit nüchtern bewerten
werden wenn es da ist der
bundeswirtschaftsminister hat es gestern
vorgestellt und zusammen mit den
netzbetreibern
festgestellt dass es aus gründen der
versorgungssicherheit sinnvoll ist
angesichts der angespannten lage im
europäischen stromnetz zwei
atomkraftwerke im süden deutschlands für
einen potenziellen notfall in reserve zu
halten
das halte ich für vernünftig damit wird
vorsorge getroffen für ein
worst-case-szenario
und gleichzeitig wird die laufzeit der
atomkraftwerke damit aber nicht
verlängert
als für die nukleare sicherheit
zuständige ministerin möchte ich dazu
zweierlei klar und deutlich sagen
atomkraft ist und bleibt eine
hochrisikotechnologie
für die atombehörden in bund und ländern
muss die nukleare sicherheit oberste
priorität haben darauf müssen sich alle
menschen in deutschland verlassen können
der beschluss zum ende der
atomkraftnutzung in deutschland wurde
hier im deutschen bundestag auch mit den
stimmen von cdu csu und fdp gefasst nach
einem gefährlichen zick-zack-kurs in
dieser frage der uns auch teuer zu
stehen gekommen ist mit diesem atom
ausstiegsbeschluss wurde ein
jahrzehntelanger
gesellschaftlicher großkonflikt beendet
und wer jetzt einsteigt in eine
diskussion um laufzeitverlängerungen
und damit in wahrheit über den
wiedereinstieg in die atomkraft nutzung
der kündigt diesen konsens auf
und das während wir alle voller sorge
auf ein atomkraftwerk schauen wenige
hundert kilometer von uns entfernt
das gegenstand des angriffskrieges
russland gegen die ukraine wurde ich
halte das für unverantwortlich
noch dazu ist unser nachbarland
frankreich gegenwärtig mit den massiven
problemen die atomkraft nutzung der
atomkraft nutzung mit
sicherheitsproblemen bei den reaktoren
mit fehlendem kühlwasser und einer
dadurch immens gefährdeten
stromversorgung wollen sie deutschland
ernsthaft wieder in die abhängigkeit
dieser problematischen stromversorgung
bringen wir wollen das ganz sicher nicht
und deshalb halten wir am atomausstieg
fest
meine damen und herren eine
umweltkatastrophe schlimmsten ausmaßes
hat sich erst vor einigen wochen eine
gute stunde von dir entfernt ereignet
das fischsterben in der oder hat uns
dramatisch vor augen geführt wirklich
dramatisch vor augen geführt wie
verhängnisvolles ist wenn ein ökosystem
das ohnehin geschwächt ist dann hitze
niedriger wasserstand und gravierende
verschmutzung hinzu kommen und ich hoffe
wirklich inständig dass sich das
ökosystem oder von den folgen dieser
katastrophe
schnell so schnell wie möglich wieder
erholen kann und dass die folgen für die
menschen die am und vom fluss leben
begrenzt bleiben können und sie
ebenfalls vom und am fluss schnell
wieder leben können im umweltausschuss
und umweltausschusses eines tages habe
ich vor letzte woche darüber berichtet
was wir was brandenburg was mecklenburg
vorpommern in die wege geleitet haben
und weiterhin tun werden um die ursache
dieser katastrophe aufzuklären und den
schaden so stark wie möglich zu
begrenzen
wir brauchen aber darüber hinaus ein
umdenken im umgang mit unseren flüssen
und gewässern denn die verändern sich
jetzt rapide und die gefahren durch
chemische einleitungen und den ausbau
von flüssen erhöhen sich der dürre
sommer zeigt wie wichtig es ist wasser
in der landschaft zu halten und in den
städten zu speichern uns auf die folgen
der klimakrise vorzubereiten und
klimaschutz zu betreiben
ich freue mich deshalb sehr dass ich
letzte woche trotz all dieser aktuellen
krisen und katastrophen das
aktionsprogramm natürlicher klimaschutz
starten konnte das bis
das bis 2026 mit vier milliarden euro
aus dem klima- und transformation vom
ausgestattet ist der natürliche
klimaschutz ermöglicht eine dreifache
dividende für den klimaschutz für den
naturschutz und für die anpassung an die
folgen der klimakrise
wälder und auen und moore meere und
gewässer naturnah grünflächen in der
stadt und auf dem land binden
kohlendioxid aus der atmosphäre
und speichern es langfristig sie nehmen
hochwasser auf und sie sorgen bei hitze
für abkühlung damit sichern sie unsere
lebensgrundlagen und unser wirtschaften
und das gerade auch für die
landwirtschaft und deshalb ist meine
priorität dieses programm jetzt
tatsächlich in die realität zu bringen
wir werden natürlich mit weiteren
maßnahmen mit unserer wasserstrategie
mit dem klima anpasst das gesetz diese
konkreten in der realität jetzt
beginnenden maßnahmen unterstützen und
die haushaltsberatungen liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen sind eine gute
gelegenheit neben den akuten
herausforderungen dann auch auf die
langfristigen krisen zu schauen und die
konzepte zur bewältigung dieser krisen
zu diskutieren vielen dank bis hierher
die ministerin für umwelt naturschutz zu
nukleare sicherheit und
verbraucherschutz ist ja seit dieser
legislatur auch ihm dem ressort mit
angesiedelt ja sie hat noch mal ganz
deutlich gesagt war es robert habe ich
ja gestern schon versucht hat zumindest
klar zu machen am geplanten atomausstieg
2022 in deutschland soll festgehalten
werden aber unter bestimmten bedingungen
könnten zwei meiler länger am netz
bleiben
haushaltsdebatten dienen der regierung
dazu ihre schwerpunkte vorzustellen sie
sind aber andererseits für die
opposition auch eine gelegenheit bilanz
zu ziehen und unsere bilanz zu ihrem
haushalt uns zu ihrer politik des
ministeriums für umwelt und
verbraucherschutz ist es wenig
überraschend
die enttäuscht uns bei den themen die
die menschen wirklich umtreiben den
hohen kosten die dringend nötigen
entlastungen da war ehrlich gesagt von
der verbraucherschutzministerin
wenig zu hören die menschen wissen nicht
wie sie im winter weiter geht wie sie
die hohen preise stimmen sollen
gleichzeitig sollen mehr als 20
millionen gaskunden mit der gas umlage
unternehmen stützen die teilweise
überhaupt nicht von einem zusammenbruch
bedroht sind das soll jetzt
nachgebessert werden aber in der ganzen
des diskussion habe ich die stimme der
verbraucherschutzministerin vermisst da
muss eine verbraucherschutzministerin
sich doch einschalten muss jedoch
alternativen entwickeln sehr geehrte
frau ministerin
werden sie ihrer verantwortung gerecht
und bringen sie sich ein die gasanlage
so wie sie jetzt konzipiert ist die kann
es so nicht geben die muss zurückgezogen
werden vom ministerium
mit dem dritten entlastungspaket werden
teilweise unsere forderungen übernommen
aber es enthält auch viele lehrstellen
und fragezeichen sie vergessen die
normalverdiener die gerade so über den
sozialhilfe setzen bieten viele
verbraucherinnen und verbraucher sind
angestellt und sind auf ihren
arbeitsplatz angewiesen wo sind die
konkreten und dringend benötigen
benötigten entlastungen für die kleinen
und mittleren unternehmen das
entlastungs paket enthält dazu nur
ankündigungen es ist derzeit völlig
unklar wie und wann die unternehmen
durch die sogenannte strompreis bremse
entlastet werden die kleinen und
mittleren unternehmen die sind doch die
den karren in deutschland ziehen die
sind doch die für das
bruttosozialprodukt verantwortlich sind
da braucht es konkrete unterstützung
sonst sehe ich für die arbeitslosenquote
in deutschland schwarz über frau
ministerin
eine neue kommission soll sich jetzt der
hohen gaspreise annehmen dass meine sehr
geehrten damen und herren dass es ein
offenbarungseid die regierung verfällt
in ein gefährliches muster wenn du nicht
mehr weiter weißt dann bilde einen
arbeitskreis aber die zeit drängt und
die verbraucherinnen und verbraucher
wollen zu recht wissen in welcher höhe
sie waren mit einer entlastung rechnen
können die belastung die steht im raum
mit der gasanlage bringen sie endlich
licht ins dunkel und nehmen sie den
menschen die angst
betrachtet man die bisher vom
bundesministerium vorgeschlagenen
gesetze die vom parlament verabschiedet
wurden steht nur die änderung des
bundesnaturschutzgesetzes zu buche das
ist ernüchternd und viel zu wenig man
muss ernsthaft die frage stellen können
sie krise haben sie die zeichen der zeit
erkannt inhaltlich ist die änderung des
bundesnaturschutzgesetzes viel zu kurz
gegriffen damit erreichen wir nicht die
dringend benötigte beschleunigung der
genehmigungsverfahren die wir für die
energiewende brauchen nur wenn wir in
allen bereichen bezüglich aller
infrastrukturvorhaben eine planungs
beschleunigung bekommen und nicht nur
bei der windenergie können wir
versorgungssicherheit gewährleisten und
klimaneutralität erreichen deshalb sage
ich lassen sie die erleichterungen für
sämtliche infrastrukturvorhaben zu und
bessern sie auch dieses gesetz nach
kroos' ministerin
zum thema kernenergie
bislang hat die regierung immer betont
es gibt in deutschland nur ein wärme
problem aber kein strom problem das war
jemand der stresstest hat jetzt gezeigt
dass es in manchen regionen deutschlands
im winter auch zu stromengpässen kommen
kann und was ist ihre reaktion zwei
kernkraftwerke in der not reserven
sollen es jetzt richten das heißt es ist
noch gar nicht klar ob sie aktiviert
werden sie müssen für viel geld
vorgehalten werden das ist ehrlich
gesagt ein schlecht davids damit haben
sie die chance auf eine sichere auf eine
bezahlbare und eine klimafreundliche
energieversorgung verpasst liebe ampel
wir müssen alle optionen nutzen wir
müssen die stromkapazitäten insgesamt
erhöhen entlastungen sind wichtig und
notwendig aber damit lösen sie das
grundproblem am strommarkt nicht nur
wenn wir das angebot erhöhen lösen wir
dieses problem nur das wird letztendlich
preis dämpfen liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
deshalb brauchen wir eine befristete es
ist kein wiedereinstieg frau ministerin
eine befristete laufzeit verlängerung
aller drei kernkraftwerke damit wir
sicher und zu bezahlbaren preisen durch
den winter kommen ihre ideologisch
geprägte politik schadet schadet unserem
land und belastet die menschen
auf das dringend benötigte
klimaanpassung gesetz lässt weiter auf
sich warten und bei diesen
herausforderungen da verwundert es schon
wenn in dem bereich die mittel auch noch
gekürzt werden im haushalt um 15
millionen euro gekürzt werden das passt
nicht zusammen
mein fazit zum haushalt ist an vielen
stellen müssen die schwerpunkte anders
gesetzt werden meine kolleginnen und
kollegen werden auch noch darauf
eingehen sie können sich sicher sein
dass wir uns konstruktiv in dieser
haushaltsdebatte einbringen parallel
dazu muss die ministerin als stimme der
verbraucherinnen und verbraucher stärker
zu hören sein die angekündigten
initiativen schneller vorlegen um die
regulierung muss in der derzeitigen
krise wirklich den menschen helfen das
sind sie ihnen schuldig vielen dank
sagt anja weisgerber für die
unionsfraktion hier in richtung der
ministerin steffi lemke die hier der
rede natürlich folgt und der
nachfolgenden debatte zu ihrem
einzelplan denn das ganze geht ja auch
noch in die beratung
und da muss man natürlich schauen wie
die fraktion sich positionieren jetzt
für die spd michael tief bei den
kolleginnen und kollegen im plenum zu
verbringen insofern bin ich sehr gern
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte damen und herren kolleginnen
kollegen
ich will vielleicht noch ein wort zur
frau weisgerber versagen als werbe die
sie lösen gleich mal mit ideen von
vorgestern nicht die probleme von heute
und wenn sie das für der atomkraft immer
wieder nach vorne bringen wir reden über
sechs prozent der energie über die sie
gerade gesprochen haben und über riesige
probleme haben die hälfte des haushaltes
mit der endlagerung von radioaktiven
abfällen zu tun wir erzeugen abfälle für
tausende von jahren für
nachfolgegeneration für eine kurze
spannende der energiegewinnung und
gerade mal sechs prozent die wir unter
anderem sein dieselbe größenordnung
momentan mit biogas erzeugen also sollte
man nicht vergessen
die derzeitige politische lage der
russische angriffskrieg der ukraine die
spannung zwischen china und taiwan die
auswirkungen der korona pandemie haben
deutschland europa deutlich vor augen
geführt
dass wir um zu exportieren und zu
produzieren im energie und rohstoff
importe aus anderen ländern brauchen um
unseren wohlstand nicht zu gefährden
auch in der fokus wie gerade eben schon
bemerkt auf energie knapper liegt gibt
es auch immer wieder verknappungen bei
rohstoffen und vorprodukten
bauprojekte verzögern sich hightech
projekte sind nicht mehr durchführbar
weil elemente fehlen die
automobilindustrie leidet unter
fehlenden ersatzteilen und teilen die
angeliefert werden wir merken also
rohstoffe wie lithium metall öle und
vieles mehr sind knapp und teuer und die
nachfrage steigt ein stück unabhängiger
von lieferungen aus anderen ländern
bringt einmal die produktion hier vor
ort aber natürlich auch und das sag ich
ja immer wieder schon seit jahren ein
hochwertiges recycling und eine
durchdachte kreislaufwirtschaft sie
stellen genau die rohstoffe hier im land
bereit die wir dringend brauchen das ist
gut für die deutsche wirtschaft und das
gut für den schutz der umwelt
damit rohstoffe nicht illegal das land
verlassen brauchen wir eine
entschlossene verfolgt von illegalen
abfalltransport und frau ministerin
lemke sie haben das ja angekündigt für
die transporte nach polen da gibt es ja
solche vorfälle wir müssen aber
insgesamt schauen dass illegale
transporte eingeschränkt werden wir
beobachten das ja seit jahren immer
wieder neue länder sie haben dabei meine
und die unterstützung meiner
spd-fraktion bei diesem vorhaben wir
sind sehr gespannt auf ihre vorschläge
in dem bereich
die herausforderungen vor denen wir
derzeit stehen sind groß aber wir werden
nicht locker lassen bei der ökologischen
transformation bei der energiewende bei
dem umbau der wirtschaft zu einer
nachhaltigen kreislaufwirtschaft
eine nachhaltige entwicklung bedeutet
eben nachfolgende generation keine haus
hohen schulden zu hinterlassen keine
unwiederbringlich zerstört die natur und
keine weiteren radioaktive abfälle für
tausende von ja vor diesem hintergrund
stehen die verhandlungen zum haushalt
des umweltministeriums und ich bin sehr
froh dass dieser haushalt eben nicht
gestrichen wurde sondern um knapp 264
millionen euro aufgestockt wurde auf
insgesamt 24 milliarden euro
ein punkt dabei der mir besonders
wichtig ist ist der nationale
meeresschutz erwächst von einer auf 22
millionen euro und ein wichtiger punkt
ist hierbei die bergung der munitions
altlasten die wir in nord und ostsee
haben insgesamt liegen dort 1,6
millionen tonnen bomben granaten
torpedos vieles andere mehr auf
chemische reste chemische kampfstoffe
und die verfallen so langsam die
korrodieren und setzten giftige substanz
sind frei die wir heute schon messen
können wir brauchen das geld dringend um
eine schwimmende plattformen auftrag zu
geben die
vollautomatisch die bergung vornimmt die
munition zerlegen kann und unschädlich
macht
mit der kollegin bettina hagedorn david
sie auch heute hier haben wir eine
veranstaltung vor kurzem gemacht und
haben mit den experten gesprochen die
noch einmal bestätigt haben dass wir
damit wirklich jetzt auch starten können
das ist aber auch nötig ist jetzt zu
starten deswegen will ich das hier an
dieser stelle noch mehr erwähnt für das
für die haushaltsnot von 2023 sind 420
millionen veranschlagt ich könnte mir
vorstellen dass wir das auch noch
erhöhen das wird sich hier innerhalb der
beratung dann noch zeigen
ein weiterer bedeutender aufruf von 26,6
millionen haben wir beim bundes
naturschutz fonds hier sind viele dinge
enthalten der wildnis vor und die augen
renaturierung das bundesprogramm
biologische vielfalt aber ich will an
dieser stelle nochmal sagen dass wir
insbesondere beim artenschutzprogramm
eben vieles vorhaben in diesem bereich
der regenerativen energie des ausbaus
der regenerativen energien insbesondere
windkraft anlagen wollen wir natürlich
dafür sorgen dass der artenschutz nicht
gefährdet wird deswegen ist dieses
programm und der stelle noch mal
besonders wichtig
ebenfalls ein aufwuchs gibt es bei dem
förderprogramm zur vermüllung der meere
für das jahr 2023 werden hier acht
millionen mehr veranschlagt ich will das
noch mal besonders erwähnen das machen
wir ja durchaus auch schon länger dieses
projekt die organisation sitzen in
deutschland die damit gefördert werden
aber die projekte finden in vietnam
indien in der karibik statt ein ganz
wichtiger beitrag für ein globales
problem eben die vermüllung der
weltmeere und ich glaube dieses geld ist
sehr gut angelegt ein förderprogramm
genau zur richtigen zeit
ein thema was neues in diesem haushalt
das aber besonders wichtig ist ist der
bereich verbraucherschutz gerade in
diesen zeiten haben wir es mit energie
knapper zu tun mit sozial ökologische
transformation mit digitalisierung und
eben dort einen besonderen bedarf auch
für den verbraucherschutz und wir haben
gerade jetzt in letzter zeit erlebt dass
verbraucher immer wieder mit schwierigen
situationen konfrontiert wurden es
wurden verträge gekündigt es wurden die
einstellung von belieferung mit strom
wurde durchgeführt unzulässige
preiserhöhungen und vieles mehr es ist
ganz wichtig dass wir die verbrauchern
verbraucher in deutschland in dieser
situation der sowieso die
herausforderungen groß sind in der aber
auch vieles schiefläuft nicht alleine
lassen dass wir dort unterstützen wo
unterstützung notwendig ist und dafür
brauchen wir auch die informationen in
diesem bereich und deswegen setzen wir
uns ein für einen bundesinstitut für
verbraucherforschung und ich würde mich
sehr freuen wenn wir es im nächsten jahr
schaffen diese institute zumindest
gleich mal zu prüfen auf den weg zu
bringen man muss dann noch drüber reden
wie es genau ausgestaltet wird aber ich
glaube eine gute idee und eine gute idee
insbesondere für die verbraucherinnen
und verbraucher in deutschland
ja die liebe kollegen ich gar nicht auf
die weiteren haushaltsverhandlungen
lassen sie uns streiten lassen wir uns
verhandeln für die besten lösungen für
die menschen in unserem land ich glaube
das ist ein ganz wichtiges ziel und wie
gesagt ich freue mich auf die nächsten
wochen vielen dank
sagt hier michael thews für die
spd-fraktion und erstmals sind wir aber
noch in dieser woche das ist ja erst der
start der haushaltsberatung der erste
tag die noch bis freitag hier andauern
mir ist zu diesem einzelplan für die afg
wolfgang wehle
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin
kolleginnen und kollegen umwelt und
naturschutz können einen wichtigen
beitrag zur bewahrung unserer heimat
leisten gelingen wird das dann wenn man
den schutz unserer heimat zum
vorrangigen ziel macht diese
bundesregierung will das aber gerade
nicht in der energiepolitik lässt sie
keinen stein auf dem anderen sie bringt
das kunststück fertig gleichzeitig die
versorgungssicherheit und viele schöne
deutsche landschaften zu zerstören
zwei prozent der fläche deutschlands
will man mit windrädern und
solarkraftwerken zu pflastern gegen
diese angst einflößenden pläne hätte das
umweltministerium mit aller kraft
widerspruch einlegen müssen
zu hören war aber nichts
es gebe alternativen der jahren setzt
sich die afg für die weitere nutzung der
kernenergie für und für innovative
besonders sichere reaktortyp inzwischen
haben viele verstanden dass das der
richtige weg ist
der ruf nach der weiternutzung der
deutschen kernkraftwerke erreicht in der
energiekrise inzwischen sturmstärke nur
an einer stelle wird er nicht begriffen
nämlich in der regierung und
insbesondere nicht in den kühlen
geführten ministerien
so war ihr haus von ministerin lemke mit
dem erheben von bedenken gegenüber
diesen kraftwerken extrem schnell wir
nimmer kann dass das ergebnis einer
gründlichen prüfung gewesen sein
stattdessen hat man offensichtlich
einfach ein grünes ideologie papier aus
der schublade gezogen sowie das aus dem
sie vorhin abgelesen haben
wenn aber ein stresstest für die
energieversorgung ansteht dauert es bei
dieser regierung wochen und monate
heraus kommt dann ein placebo völlig
wirkungslos gegen die explodierenden
strompreis
im haushalt des umweltministeriums
könnte man durch eine
zukunftsorientierte energiepolitik
vielleicht sparen wir dürfen erwarten
dass moderne reaktortypen die
langlebigen nuklearen reststoffe älterer
kraftwerke als brennstoff verwenden
können schade herr kollege tiefs dass
sie dieses konzept anscheinend nicht
kennen dann erübrigt sich nämlich eine
endlagerung weitgehend und man hätte mit
diesem thema erheblich weniger aufwand
mehr
aufwand plant das umweltministerium
künftig für sachverständige und für
dienstreisen ein daran dass berater
unwesen wo hat also weiter und
videokonferenzen statt dienstreisen
empfiehlt das ministerium höchstens
antike
an dieser stelle habe ich schon bei der
letzten haushaltsberatung das
umweltbundesamt angesprochen ich fordere
es erneut dazu auf zu akzeptieren dass
immer mehr menschen holz als
nachwachsenden rohstoff zum heizen
verwenden das versagen der
energiepolitik macht das für viele zur
existenzfrage
ein verbot von holzfeuerungen wäre daher
sind
in bayern
macht man sogar schon ausnahmen von
bereits verhängten verbote aufklärung
über das richtige heizen mit holz statt
verbotspolitik das wäre das gebot der
stunde aber
in der regierung glaubt man immer noch
mit grüner politik könnte man die welt
hält dabei stehen die zeichen des
scheiterns längst an der wand
realistisch wäre es daher
maßnahmen zur anpassung an den
klimawandel stärker zu fördern aber
ausgerechnet hier soll der haushalt um
ein viertel gekürzt werden es gibt also
viel zu verbessern die fdp fraktion wird
das im nächsten wochen in aller klarheit
einfach
[Applaus]
für die fdp-fraktion hat nun die
kollegin judith skudelny das wort
an sie ist die obfrau im ausschuss für
umwelt nukleare sicherheit
verbraucherschutz und naturschutz
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen auch der
haushalt 2023 im umwelt und
verbraucherschutz bereich steht im
zeichen der zeitenwende steht im zeichen
der krise die ausgelöst wurde durch
putins und russlands
völkerrechtswidrigen angriffskrieg auf
und in der ukraine
dieser angriffskrieg hat natürlich auch
auf uns einfluss und einer dieser
einflüsse sehen wir ganz aktuell auf den
energiemärkten im bereich der
energiepolitik
jede bundesregierung auch diese
bundesregierung hat ein versprechen den
menschen in deutschland und der
wirtschaft in deutschland einzulösen es
ist die das versprechen nach sichere
saubere und bezahlbare energie und
dieses versprechen wird die ampel
regierung einlösen
wir haben schon gesehen das natürlich
nicht alles einfach es in der stresstest
zeigt dass die netzsicherheit
insbesondere im frühjahr nächsten jahres
nicht an jedem punkt gegeben ist es ist
einfach so da kann man noch darüber
reden wie scharf die situation ist aber
wir werden dinge tun müssen und so
robert habeck hat ja gesagt bewerben
wahrscheinlich ein reservebetrieb für
das frühjahr
2023 benötigen jetzt gibt es aber eine
sache die liegt uns als fdp ein bisschen
auf der seele wir wissen dass wir die
gaslieferungen aus russland bis ins jahr
2024 werden problemlos ersetzen können
durch elend ihren wasserstoff das
bedeutet aber dass wir noch einen herbst
und im frühjahr vor uns haben und wände
das atomgesetz in die hand nehmen um
eine sicherung der stromversorgung in
deutschland für das frühjahr 2003 20 zu
machen dann müssen wir uns doch auch
fragen was ist bis in das jahr 2024 rein
und deswegen möchten und werden wir
darüber diskutieren ob wir nicht anstatt
einem plättchen bis ins frühe nächsten
jahres nicht einen vernünftigen plan für
die energiesicherheit bis 2024 machen
sollte
das würde uns übrigens auch aus einem
weiteren klemme befreien nämlich die
klemme zwischen sicher und sauber
unterscheiden zu müssen wir waren noch
sicher und sauber und deswegen wollen
wir eben nicht kohle und öl hochfahren
sondern wir wollen eine
energieversorgung wie dem klimaschutz
rechnung trägt und das müssen wir auch
im jahr 2023 im blick behalten wir
wollen strom sicherheit wollen
energiesicherheit und wir wollen
klimaschutz gemeinsam meist
bleibt noch das kleine thema war und
ganz ehrlich die menschen in deutschland
die wirtschaft und die verbraucherin
verbraucher merken dass das thema
bezahlbare energieversorgung kräftig ins
wanken wie es jeder merkt es weil sich
aber viele leute merken es tatsächlich
schon ein bisschen existenzielle grenzen
hinweg und deswegen ist es richtig und
notwendig dass diese bundesregierung die
nöte der menschen aufgreift und 1 65
milliarden entlastungspaket vorgelegt
hat dafür mit dem alle fans von ihrer
seite war dazu ein sind gar nichts
gesagt diese um etwas was sie
kriegen nämlich eine entlastung der
mittelschicht in deutschland durch den
abbau der kalten progression nicht erst
bei der inflation überfällig wir geben
den leuten zurück was sie verdienen und
zeigen dass sich leistung in deutschland
lohnt
wir entlasten rentnerinnen und rentner
auszubildende studenten und
geringverdiener wir geben ihnen die
möglichkeit ihre energierechnung zu
zahlen und wir geben den menschen ein
versprechen ab nämlich die die sich
bemühen die versuchen ihre stromrechnung
zu zahlen die wegen mir sogar noch kalt
duschen und trotzdem in existenzielle
nöte kommen dem versprechen wir es wird
keine strom und gas sparend in
deutschland geben für diese menschen das
ist verbraucherschutz in krisenzeiten
dass es was ich an die regierung auf den
weg gebracht hat und das ist was wir den
menschen versprechen können
noch an dieser stelle eine kleine
bemerkung ich habe noch eine minute 20
nicht möchte gerade am heutigen tag an
etwas erinnern was wir auch den menschen
versprochen haben als fdp
gestern haben die trilog verhandlungen
zur zukunft des kolben motors ab 2035
bekommen die fdp hat im
koalitionsvertrag durchgesetzt dass es
eine zukunft für den verbrennungsmotor
ab 2035 geben wird wenn er klimaneutral
gefahren werden kann wir haben in der
bundesregierung uns durchgesetzt und
eingesetzt dafür dass im europarat ein
entsprechender beschluss gefasst wird
und wir werden uns weiterhin mit auges
augen darauf achten dass das nicht ein
papiertiger wird sondern dass dieser
beschluss eingang findet in die
europäische beschlusslage dass der
klimaneutrale verbrennungsmotor mit
synthetischen und i tunes kraftstoffe
eine zukunft hat das ist ein versprechen
das wir als fdp fraktion den menschen
gegeben haben ein kompromiss den wir
verhandelt haben und wofür wir sorge
tragen
dass er in der ampel regierung auch
umgesetzt wird auf europäischer ebene
judith skudelny war das für die hält
liberalen hier am rednerpult und naja
innerhalb der koalition ist man
zumindest noch nicht ganz einig was die
atomlaufzeiten 1 gelang nämlich das was
robert habeck gäste angekündigt hat dass
die beiden süddeutschen atommeiler im
standby modus gehalten werden sollen bei
bedarf innerhalb von einer woche
hochgefahren werden können das bleibt
hinter den forderungen der fdp zurück
frau präsident sie meine damen und
herren das umweltministerium hat 2,4
milliarden euro zur verfügung
das sind nur 0 5 prozent des haushalts
aber selbst von diesem bisschen fließt
mehr als die hälfte nicht in den
naturschutz sondern die lagerung von
atommüll
ehrlicherweise ist frau lemke nicht
umweltministerin sondern ministerin für
atommüll wir finden völlig falsch dass
die ampel koalition die umweltpolitik so
runter fährt es muss mehr getan wir
müssen mehr geld für die umwelt ausgeben
und ausgerechnet jetzt
öffnen grüne minister die tür für den
weiterbetrieb der atomkraftwerke obwohl
die seit jahren keine gültigen
sicherheitsnachweise mehr haben das ist
verantwortungslos und
künstler sind für die sicherheit
zuständig wo bleibt eigentlich ihre
kritik alle umweltverbände haben die
entscheidung von gestern deutlich
kritisiert das ist ein kniefall vor der
atomlobby die jetzt morgenluft mit hat
frau denke
sie sind sogar die erste
umweltministerin die sich gesprächen mit
den menschen verweigert die von atommüll
betroffen sind bei mir in niedersachsen
soll der alte schacht konrad endlagern
für 95 prozent des deutschen atommülls
werden das ist vor 40 jahren
ohne faires verfahren und ohne gute
argumente so entschieden wurden selbst
der chef der atombehörde wolfram könig
hat gesagt heute würde man ein solches
bergwerk nicht nehmen wie können sie da
frau lemke
der stadt sei twitter den
umweltverbänden den landwirten das
gespräch verweigern der
oberbürgermeister sagt über sie ich habe
selten eine solche ignoranz haltung in
berlin erlebt wir sagen recht hat er
der naturschutzbund
stellt jetzt entsetzt fest dass eine
grüne umweltministerin das gespräch über
sicherheitsprobleme mit atommüll
verweigert zitat ende
beim skandal atommülllager asse 2 auch
in niedersachsen dasselbe mit eiskalter
machtpolitiker will frau lemke ein
zwischenlager mitten in einer tour
schutzgebiet setzen ohne alternativen zu
prüfen und sie lehnt gespräche mit den
betroffenen ab und stattdessen
stattdessen hat die letzten wochen sich
ausgiebig zeit dafür genommen für die
grünen auf wahlkampftour durch in
sachsen zu gehen das ist wirklich
skandalös und ist eine unverschämtheit
nicht nur den menschen die mit ihnen
sprechen wollen die von ihrer politik
betroffen sind sie machen weiter
mannschaft ihre arbeit als ministerin zu
machen wollen können
fazit der umweltschutz kommt bei dieser
regierung genauso unter die räder wie
das soziale wir werden als linke weiter
druck machen damit sich das endlich
ändern
ja und während victor perli für die
grünen hier gesprochen hat und auch
steffi lemke die bundesumweltministerin
angesprochen sie gingen die kopf
geschüttelt
hat aber jetzt natürlich keine
möglichkeit mehr darauf zu erwidern ja
schacht konrad ist ja soll ja eine
endlager für schwach und
mittelradioaktive abfälle werden in
niedersachsen
die kolleginnen der einzelplan des
bundesministeriums für umwelt
naturschutz
nukleare sicherheit und
verbraucherschutz wächst an michael
thews hat gesagt das ist gerade jetzt in
diesen schwierigen zeiten ein wichtiges
signal
es gibt allerdings ein großes aber ein
großer anteil der mittel ist durch die
zwischen- und endlagerung von atommüll
gebunden
atomenergie kostet uns alle viel geld
und zwar noch lange nachdem wir den
letzten meiler abgeschaltet haben die
ausgaben für die zwischen- und
endlagerung machen im jahr 2023 nach den
planungen der bundesregierung
1,16 milliarden euro aus das sind 48
prozent des gesamthaushalts dieses
ressorts im finanzplanungszeitraum sind
es über zwei milliarden euro allein für
die zwischenlagerung dazu kommen für die
endlagerung und das
standortauswahlverfahren noch einmal 4
milliarden euro das ist grundsätzlich
aus dem fonds zur finanzierung der
kerntechnischen entsorgung zu
finanzieren aber der verbleiben
natürlich erhebliche risiken beim start
die stilllegung des endlagers morsleben
und die stilllegung der schachtanlage
asse zwei sind nicht refinanzierbar
allein die stilllegung von asse 2 wird
bis zum beginn der rückholung das ist
nach dem jetzigen stand im jahr 2033
etwa 3,1 milliarden euro kosten die
stilllegung von morsleben bis zum
projektende 20 28 etwa 420 millionen
euro ein endlager für den für
hochradioaktive abfälle ist noch lange
nicht in sicht meine damen und herren
von der union und leider muss ich das
auch manchen kolleginnen in der fdp
sagen sie wollen mit der atomenergie
eine brücke bauen aber diese brücke ist
unsicher teuer und führt ins nichts
angesichts dieser summen ist es
besonders wichtig umwelt natur und
verbraucherschutz
effektiv und effizient zu betreiben
dabei geht es um priorisierung manche
situationen sind besonders akut da
können unsere antworten nicht warten wir
hatten im sommer das dramatische
fischsterben an der oder die ursachen
sind nicht vollständig geklärt aber es
ist wichtig dass wir mit angemessenen
maßnahmen reagieren können sobald klar
ist was wir an der oder brauchen und das
werden wir natürlich während der
haushaltsverhandlungen beobachten und
dann entsprechend agieren es gibt
genauso für die munition zu lasten in
der nord und ostsee die korrigieren und
zunehmend höhere schäden und kosten
verursachen werden wir nicht zügig
einschreiten und wir müssen die
voraussetzungen dafür schaffen dass die
freigegebenen mittel auch abfließen und
projekte in zukunft in der größenordnung
und geschwindigkeit umgesetzt werden die
im haushalt vorgesehen sind das ist
gerade beim natürlichen klimaschutz ganz
besonders wichtig das wird der
schwerpunkt unserer haushalts
behandlungen seien ich freue mich auf
die beratungen mit dem geschätzten
kolleginnen und dem ministerium
herzlichen dank
attackierte bastian schäfer für die
grünen der obmann im haushaltsausschuss
die haushälter die sind ja dann in den
nächsten wochen monaten besonders
gefragt wenn es dann noch mal alle
einzel lehne geht und es darf einen
wechsel im bundestagsgremium
petra pau die
bundestagsvizepräsidentin ist jetzt von
altern böses abgelöst worden die jetzt
die sitzung leitet
[Applaus]
[Musik]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin verehrte
kolleginnen und kollegen seit einem
dreiviertel jahr ist die ampel koalition
nun im amt schon bei den beratungen zum
nachtragshaushalt
2022 hat meine fraktion die mangelnde
klarheit kritisiert damals bekam er zur
antwort es handelt es sich nur um einen
übergangs haushalt und somit hatten wir
erwartet dass dieser entwurf deutlich
klarer und eindeutiger sei leider
fehlanzeige
ein blick in den vor uns liegenden
entwurf führt mich zu der erkenntnis
dass eigentlich wirklich mehr fragen als
antworten bleiben
immer wieder kündigen sie viele vorhaben
an aktions strategie und maßnahmenpläne
meist aber fehlt die entsprechende
finanzielle planung für ihre vorhaben
dazu ein paar beispielen
vor einem jahr hat die damalige
umweltministerin die eckpunkte zur
nationalen basars strategie vorgelegt
jetzt gibt es einen entwurf dafür der
nationalen wasserstrategie der sich bis
zur abstimmung befindet
die wasserstrategie soll antworten geben
die wir bis zum jahr 2050 zu einem
nachhaltigen umgang mit wasser und
gewässern kommen der entwurf ist den
sieg in vielen punkten richtig der
angehängte aktionsplan ausgesprochen
ambitioniert
um beides weckte hohe erwartungen
allerdings vom ministerium fehlt es an
einen konkreten maßnahmenplan der die
vorhaben priorisiert und im übrigen auch
finanziert hier bleiben sie sämtliche
antworten schuldig welche kosten werden
für bisher
welche kosten werden sie bisher fehlende
flächen parametern renaturierungen
entstehen wer trägt die finanziellen
belastungen die auch in zukunft durch
wetter extreme wie starkregen hochwasser
oder bürger entstehen werden welche
investitionen sind beispielsweise
erforderlich um die personellen und
technischen kapazitäten unserer
wasserwirtschaftsverwaltung bundesweit
zu sichern wie soll eine vierte
reinigungsstufe in der fläche konkret
finanziert werden länder und kommunen
und alle bereiche der wirtschaft und
verwaltung müssen aber wissen was auf
sie zukommt das ist auch in diesem
haushalt nicht ersichtlich ein zweiter
punkt bei dem ich klarheit vermisse ist
die bergung der circa 1,6 millionen
tonnen munitions altlasten in nord und
ostsee die bundesregierung will noch in
diesem jahr den bau einer plattform in
auftrag geben um die munition zu bergen
diese berge bergungs plattform soll etwa
100 millionen euro kosten so erste
schätzungen für das jahr 2023 planen sie
20 millionen euro im haushalt ein wenn
die plattform jedoch wie von ihnen schon
geschrieben
2024 und 25 schon arbeiten soll dann
muss ich jetzt schon die frage stellen
woher kommen die anderen 80 millionen
euro es ist nicht in der weitergehenden
finanzplanung zu finden die an nord und
ostsee gelegenen bundesländer wollen sie
finanziell beteiligen das ist diesen
bundesländern auch durchaus klar
allerdings haben sie da mittlerweile
gespräche aufgenommen
meines wissens nicht
oberflächlich betrachtet erwecken sie in
ihrem haushaltsentwurf den eindruck sie
würden schnell handeln
tatsächlich sind aber baubeginn der
blood der plattform und durchführung der
erprobung nicht durchfinanziert und
damit völlig offen
bei der gelegenheit stellt sich auch die
frage was ist eigentlich aus ihrem
angekündigten sofortprogramm zur bergung
der munitions altlasten geworden das
dritte beispiel ist das dramatische
fischsterben an der oder es ist völlig
klar
dass es zum gegenwärtigen zeitpunkt noch
einen erheblichen bedarf an aufklärung
der ursachen gibt es ist wichtig dass
die verursacher und eventuelle
behördliche fehler gefunden werden es
ist auch klar dass die aufklärungsarbeit
mit in zusammenarbeit mit polen sehr
schwierig ist aber gerade deshalb können
wir nicht warten bis alle haftungsfragen
geklärt sind bereits heute entstehen in
den entsprechenden bundesländern kosten
und zwar nicht nur für die länder
sondern auch für die betroffenen
kommunen unternehmen aber auch durchaus
privatleute sind sie mit diesen ländern
darüber im gespräch
wer welche kosten übernimmt werden
unmittelbar und mittelbar betroffenen
entschädigt auch darauf gibt der
haushaltsentwurf keine antwort
genauso wenig übrigens wie für die
anfallenden kosten zur behebung der
schäden am ökosystem
oder wollen sie damit auch die kommunen
und die länder allein gelassen
sehr geehrte frau ministerin
die ziele und die ideen ihre ziele ihre
ideen und auch die ziele und ideen der
gesamten regierung sind sicher nicht
alle falsch sind meistens sehr
ambitioniert und werden stets sehr
eloquent vorgetragen und öffentlich
nicht wirksam präsentiert die
finanzielle ausstattung dazu allerdings
die bleibt häufig auf der strecke
oder ist nicht vorhanden ist unklar
keiner weiß es sie arbeiten ganz oft mit
wirklich ungedeckten schecks damit
laufen sie gefahr dass aus ihrer
koalition des aufbruchs des fortschritts
eine koalition der luftnummern wird
dieser haushaltsentwurf
lässt mehr fragen offen als er
beantwortet ist nicht ungewöhnlich wir
werden die nächsten wochen dazu nutzen
von ihnen antworten einzufordern und
unsererseits ihnen unsere ideen
vorzulegen bedanke mich für ihre
aufmerksamkeit
als nächstes erhält das wort für die
spd-fraktion jakob blankenburg
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte frau umweltministerin lemke
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen meine
damen und herren haben wir in den
vergangenen wochen aus dem fenster
geblickt oder in die zeitung geschaut
dann sagen wir dürfen unsere haustür mit
trockene flussbetten und seen verseuchte
fischen in der oder wir haben es eben
gerade gehört brennende wälder fast
überall in europa überschwemmungen in
pakistan und gigantische müllinseln in
unseren ozean diese phänomene die sind
ausdruck einer vielzahl von globalen
krisen der klimakrise der biodiversitäts
krise und auch der müllkrise
und diese krisen die finden längst nicht
mehr nur am anderen ende der welt statt
sondern auch hier bei uns in der
direkten nachbarschaft
und diese krisen müssen uns eine warnung
aber auch eine handlungsaufforderung
sein wenn wir es ernst meinen mit dem
anspruch unseren planeten auch für
zukünftige generationen lebenswert zu
halten
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen deshalb
ist es gut dass der haushalt des
bundesumweltministeriums
für das kommende jahr über den wir hier
heute beraten mehr geld zur bekämpfung
der ursachen und auswirkungen eben
dieser krisen vorsieht
die klimakrise wurde in den letzten
wochen und monaten bereits deutlich
spürbar 98 prozent der fläche
deutschlands
das muss man sich mal auf der zunge
zergehen lassen sind von dürre
betroffenen flüsse und seen tragen so
wenig wasser das schifffahrtswege nicht
mehr passierbar sind das
industrieanlagen und kraftwerke nicht
mehr ausreichend gekühlt sind da lohnt
sich auch ein blick zu unseren
freundinnen und freunden nach frankreich
gerade vor dem hinflug der debatte und
der punkte die wir auch in diesem in
dieser in dieser debatte eben gerade
gehört haben neben dem zu wenig an
wasser das in diesem sommer unübersehbar
ist hat sich der vergangene woche
vergangenen sommer mit den reißenden
fluten im aartal in unser kollektives
gedächtnis eingebrannt
dürre und starkregen das im zwei seiten
derselben medaille
und beide haben zerstörerische wirkung
deshalb sieht der haushalt des
bundesumweltministeriums für das nächste
jahr mehr als die doppelte summe für den
klimawandel gerechten hochwasserschutz
und so klimawandel gerechten
wasserversorgung vor und zum
jahreswechsel wird das
bundesumweltministerium außerdem eine
nationale wasserstrategie mit dem ziel
eines integrierten wassermanagements
vorlegen das gemeinsam mit den ländern
eine leitlinie zur wasserentnahme
entwickelt die der öffentlichen
trinkwasserversorgung dann auch den
vorrang ein sind aber schauen wir uns
die nächste krise an auch die
biodiversitäts krise war für uns lange
abstrakt dabei war der rückgang der
artenvielfalt bei jahre an dramatischen
zahlen ablesbar
aber die korona pandemie die unseren
alltag so sehr verändert hat wie kaum
etwas zuvor die hat uns gezeigt dass
unser raubbau an der natur nicht
folgenlos bleibt mit dem eindringen des
menschen in natürliche ökosysteme und
dem verlust von lebensräumen da werden
zu müssen also krankheiten die von
tieren auf menschen überspringen von
jahr zu jahr häufiger im haushalt für 20
23 ist deshalb deutlich mehr geld für
die natur und artenschutz vorgesehen und
das gerade erst beschlossene arten
hilfsprogramm das trägt hier ein
wichtiger schritt bei
die dritte krise auf die ich in dieser
rede prägt blicken möchte dass es die
müllkrise um nachhaltig etwas gegen die
immer weitere vermittlung der weltmeere
zu tun wird im bundes im haushalt des
bundesumweltministeriums ein budget für
die förderung von technologien gegen die
vermüllung der meere eingeplant es
ergänzt die jahrelangen anstrengungen
der eu und deutschlands für eine
verbesserte kreislaufwirtschaft zu denen
auch das in diesem jahr neu aufgelegte
programm reparieren statt wegwerfen
gehabt
meine damen und herren all diese
maßnahmen und budgets leisten einen
wichtigen beitrag um die globalen umwelt
krisen zu bewältigen
damit damit sie mehr sind als ein
pflaster auf einem verwundbaren planeten
müssen wir es aber schaffen langfristig
um zu steuern um unser wirtschaften und
unser individuell individuelles
verhalten angehen wie alle aber ganz
besonders wir parlamentarierinnen und
parlamentarier stehen gemeinsam in der
verantwortung die lebensgrundlage für
uns aber auch für die zukünftigen
generationen zu bewahren damit das
gelingt braucht es mehr nachhaltigkeit
in allen lebens und wirtschaftsbereichen
lassen sie uns gemeinsam daran arbeiten
der haushalt des
bundesumweltministeriums für das
kommende jahr leistet dazu einen
wichtigen beitrag und ich freue mich
schon auf die beratung im ausschuss
vielen dank
als nächstes folgt für die afg fraktion
thomas erhorn
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin meine damen und herren
liebe mitbürger die umwelt und
energiepolitik dieser ampel koalition
ist eine symbiose aus
ideologischen fanatismus und fachlicher
inkompetenz nach jahrzehntelangen
aufschwung und wachsendem wohlstand in
der nachkriegszeit erleben wir nun eine
geradezu absurde weichenstellung für
eine dauer für den dauerhaften
wohlstandsverlust und die verarmung
unserer bevölkerung dass diese deutsche
selbstzerstörungs politik dabei irgend
einen messbaren einfluss auf das
weltklima hätte das kann man wohl nur
denen ein reden die sich auf dem
intellektuellen niveau einer greta
thunberg bewegen reden wir mal über
windkraftanlagen
neben der unfassbaren zerstörung unserer
naturlandschaften stellt sich nun heraus
dass in ihren schaltanlagen das
isolations gas sf6 verwendet wird und zu
großen teilen anschließend in die
atmosphäre gelangt schwefelhexafluorid
um den faktor 26 tausend mal
klimaschädlicher als co2
erzeugt nach einem bericht des magazins
plusminus schon heute einen
treibhauseffekt der größer ist als der
der gesamten des gesamten innerdeutschen
luftverkehr
reden wir mal über die verkehrswende im
kongo zb hinterlässt der kobalt abbau
für unsere auto batterien vergiftetes
wasser vergiftete böden und vernichtete
lebensgrundlagen für die menschen vor
ort und wofür damit sich eine grüne
schickeria in münchen und berlin
in ihrem elektroauto fälschlicherweise
ein reden kann sie täten etwas für das
weltklima aber reden wir ruhig mal über
das weltklima ich weiß nicht ob es schon
irgendjemandem in diesem hause
aufgefallen ist dass sich wären wir über
die vorteile von last von
lasten fahrrädern räsonieren sich gerade
die bevölkerung der in afrika bis 2050
fast verdoppeln wird von 1,3 auf 2,5
milliarden menschen könnte es also
vielleicht sein dass wir bezüglich klima
und umwelt dieser erde ganz andere
probleme haben als tempo 130 auf
deutschen autobahnen dass manche von
denen die außer einem abgebrochenen
studium in ihrer vita nichts vorzuweisen
haben nicht in der lage sind derartige
prioritäten zu erkennen das glaube ich
wohl wird wer aber absichtsvoll die
gesicherte energieversorgung eines
industrielandes abschneidet zerstört
damit nachhaltig die lebensgrundlagen
der eigenen bevölkerung aber glauben sie
mir wenn die menschen im winter ihre
gasrechnung nicht mehr zahlen können
wenn heizung und duschwasser kalt
bleiben wird den menschen klar werden
dass wir keinen gast notstand haben wir
haben einen regierungs notstand vielen
dank
als nächster redner erhält frank
schäffler für die fdp-fraktion das wort
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin meine lieben
kolleginnen kollegen
im einzelplan 16
gibt es auf koalitionsseite ein paar
themen wo wir einen grundkonsens haben
wo wir einer meinung sind wo wir auch
was tun wollen viele dieser dinge sind
schon erwähnt worden also die
beseitigung des mittelmeeres mülls dass
hier die mittel aufgestockt werden ist
sicherlich sinnvoll ja hier müssen wir
glaube ich auch verstärkt das prinzip
durchsetzen
auch das hochwasser auch die erhöhung
des hochwasserschutz etats ist notwendig
auch hier glaube ich können wir haben
umwelt ata sehr sehr viel erreichen und
ich glaube das thema
meeresschutz und auch das auch schon
angesprochen worden ist etwas wo wir
auch ein schwerpunkt im haus legen
müssen und wo wir in den diesen
haushaltsberatung auch noch mehr tun
müssen und auch tun können weil ich
glaube dass
auch schon gesagt worden von vom
geburtstagskind heute dass es da
natürlich auch
eine zeitfrage ist hier müssen wir
schnell handeln damit wir auch die
munition beseitigen möglichst auch auf
see beseitigen können damit man das
nicht umfangreich an land machen muss
mit all den gefahren die damit
zusammenhängen
es ist auch schon und kollegen schäfer
das thema vor zur finanzierung
kerntechnischer entsorgung angesprochen
worden ich finde das ist eigentlich ein
sehr gutes beispiel wie wir das problem
der kosten der kerntechnischen
entsorgung in der vergangenheit gelöst
haben sagen ein vorbildliches projekt
die industrie den der dem damals der
weiterbetrieb der kernkraftwerke
untersagt wurde hat letztendlich
24 milliarden in eine stiftung gepackt
die dazu dienen soll die finanzierung
der kerntechnischen sorge in der
nächsten jahrzehnten aus zu finanzieren
und das funktioniert auch sehr sehr gut
ist inzwischen die größte stiftung in
deutschland ist professionell gemanagt
und das ist etwas finde ich auch dass
wir durchaus auch stolz sein können dass
wir das in diesem land geschafft haben
denn wir haben sehr häufig probleme
kapitalsammelstellen in großem stil zu
schaffen wir haben wir mal eine
geschaffen die auch erfolgreich am markt
agiert und die gelder mehr und nicht
reduziert aber wir haben ja und die
ministerin hat das angesprochen und
deshalb würde ich das hier an dieser
stelle auch tun es gibt natürlich auch
ein dissens
und er hat natürlich etwas mit mit dem
zu tun was wir aktuell erleben ja wenn
die strompreise sich verzehnfachen wenn
die gaspreise sich verzehnfachen dann
muss man natürlich schauen wie man mit
diesem problem umgeht und da ist die
gasanlage und die negative eeg-umlage
ein thema wo man ran muss und da ist ja
der wirtschaftsminister bei diese themen
anzugehen aber
es geht auch um die angebotsseite wir
müssen auch die angebotsseite erhöhen
und da reicht es eben nicht und da ist
ein großer unterschied 3 das eben nicht
nur notfall kraftwerke kernkraftwerke im
markt zu haben weil das eben nicht das
angebot erhöht sondern wahrscheinlich
weil die auch vergütet werden für diese
zeit sogar die preise noch tendenziell
erhöht also es wird nicht dazu führen
dass bis das energie das strom und gas
in diesem land billiger werden sondern
es löst das problem nicht und deshalb
glaube ich müssen wir wieder verstärkt
auch über die kernenergie in diesem land
konstruktiv reden das machen wir zu
wenig ja man muss ja begründen warum man
nur zwei dieser kernkraftwerke jetzt in
diesen zustand versetzt und nicht das
beste kernkraftwerk was wir in
deutschland haben in lingen im emsland
außen vor lässt das erschließt sich mir
nicht dafür gibt es aus meiner sicht
keine nachprüfbaren
begründung zum 2 1 und 2
meine dinge meine meinen gedanken zu
ende führen sie erlauben keine zwischen
der lage aus der afg fragt seien gut und
dann ist es so dass wir 2009 10 36
prozent der des grundlastfähigen stroms
über kernenergie
bestritten haben inzwischen sind es nur
noch rund sechs prozent hätten wir das
damals in dieser form nicht gemacht dann
werden wir jetzt nicht in diese
erpressungs situation hinein gekommen in
der wir heute sind das letztendlich das
letzte kraftwerk das erb gaskraftwerk
den strompreis für alle anderen
bestritten bestimmt und deshalb haben
wir in deutschland eben nicht nur ein
gas problem sondern wir haben natürlich
auch ein stromproblem und wenn man das
als zuständiger minister nicht wahr ich
glaube dann hat man auch ein problem
denn das ist die grundlage unseres strom
und energie marktes in deutschland und
deshalb glaube ich muss man da noch
etwas nachsitzen vielen dank
der frank schäffler für die liberalen
war das und
beim thema kernenergie
jeden im moment zumindest die liberalen
und die grünen nicht so hundertprozentig
in eine richtung er hat es ja auch noch
mal angesprochen
gibt es aber noch mal eine
dass die zwischenfrage nicht zu
schließen haben deswegen stelle ich sie
jetzt ihnen sicherlich bekannt dass wir
einen gesetzentwurf vorgelegt haben den
paragraph 7 atomgesetz zu ändern so dass
quasi die drei restlichen kernkraftwerke
erst einmal weiterlaufen könnten gehe
ich dann richtig in der annahme wenn sie
davon überzeugt sind dass für die
weiterlaufen lassen sollten dass sie
ihre fraktion empfehlen werden diesem
gesetzentwurf in der zweiten dritten
lesung dann zuzustimmen vielen dank herr
abgeordneter waren sie antworten
erkennbar herr kollege wir bilden ja
eine fragt eine koalition aus
fdp spd und grünen einen
koalitionsvertrag
vereinbart haben wir dinge
niedergeschrieben die in der heutigen
zeit ziemlich einen realitätscheck
brauchen und das haben wir
beim thema bundeswehr schon gemacht auch
bei den investitionen holen wir jetzt
zusätzlich nach und ich bin auch ganz
optimistisch dass die koalition auch in
dieser frage was die kernenergie
betrifft
zu weiteren schritten kommen wird da
müssen wir eigentlich auf den leim gehen
vielen dank
vielen dank als nächstes erhält das wort
für die linke der abgeordnete reif lenk
hat
und ralph lenkert ist er obmann im
ausschuss für klimaschutz und energie
für die linke eine frau präsidentin
kolleginnen und kollegen in den letzten
fünf jahren ist 2022 das vierte hitze
und doria auch in deutschland fordern
wälder trockenen schlüsse aus was sich
aus meiner jugendzeit nicht kannte im
thüringer becken gibt es eigentlich
beste böden für gute ernten fehlt der
regen und wenn er kommt dann oft als
unwetter der klimawandel trifft uns
bereits hat ministerin lemke kündigte
eine klima anpassungsstrategie an aber
trotz klimakrise sind mehr mittel für
klimaanpassung fehlanzeige die ampel hat
versagt
ich fordere sie auf hören sie
beispielsweise die gelder für unseren
wald von 121 millionen auf eine
milliarde für schnelleren waldumbau
damit unsere wälder starkregen speichern
können hochwasser abmildern
grundwasserneubildung unterstützen und
somit auch dem austrocknen der flüsse
vorbeugen dieses jahr voller verlor
deutschland durch waldbrände bis august
über 4500 hektar wald das darf so nicht
weitergehen
wir müssen weit brände verhindern
schneller löschen im aartal traf beim
hochwasser die gesamte
trinkwasserversorgung zusammen und immer
öfter auch in deutschland die
trinkwasserversorgung kritisch der dank
der bundesregierung an die einsatzkräfte
die brände löschten an die männer und
frauen die trinkwasserversorgung wieder
herstellten mussten heute wie ein hohn
vorkommen gerade tobt im harz ein
waldbrand auf 150 hektar und die ampel
kürzt die gelder für den bau und erhalt
von lösch teilchen und löschwasser
entnahmestellen von zehn auf zwei
millionen euro das ist fahrlässig die
ampel streicht die meist mittel für die
note grund die im katastrophenfall wie
an der art die versorgung mit
trinkwasser absichern sollen das ist
grob fahrlässig
nehmen sie die kürzung zurück darauf
weisen sie die kameraden kameraden von
feuerwehr und thw wirklich respekt
lassen sie mich abschließend sagen ich
finde es eine schande für deutschland
wenn für klimaschutz für klimaanpassung
für soziale belange beim geld gekleckert
wird aber sobald es um aufrüstung gegen
geklotzt wird das ist keine
zukunftsweisende politik fehlen
sagt hier ralph lenkert für die
linksfraktionen
es folgt doktor jan die classe gesenhues
für die grünen
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen lassen sie nicht vorab sagen
dass sich der bundesregierung sehr
dankbar dafür bin dass sie unsere
versorgungssicherheit einem realitäts
check unterzogen hat und mit einem
stresstest pragmatisch und ideologiefrei
geprüft hat und robert habeck einen
intelligenten vorschlag gemacht hat und
ich freue mich wenn sie den auch
unterstützen
viele rednerinnen und redner haben
darauf hingewiesen wir machen politik in
einer krisenhaften zeit die krise
scheint schon normalzustand der politik
geworden zu sein was dramatisch ist und
dann gibt es immer die üblichen
verdächtigen die dann in so einer krise
danach rufen ja jetzt müssen wir mal
zurück drehen beim umwelt- und
naturschutz liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen ich halte das für extrem
gefährlich weil umgekehrt ist es doch
war umwelt und naturschutz sind nicht
teil des problems sondern sie sind teil
der lösung sie sind teil der lösung um
unsere ernährung zu sichern diese teil
der lösung ernährung zu sichern weil wir
intakte böden brauchen weil wir intakte
artenvielfalt brauchen sie sind teil der
lösung gerade auch im bereich
kreislaufwirtschaft kollege tipps
angesprochen um unsere rohstoff
sicherheit zu gewährleisten und natur
und umweltschutz sind wichtig um unsere
sicherheit zu gewährleisten denn freies
und sicheres leben gibt es nur auf einem
intakten planeten meine damen und herren
und vor diesem hintergrund es ist auch
gut dass der haushalt des
bundesumweltministeriums
solide finanziert ist wir stärken auch
noch mal das bundesumweltministerium als
wichtiges haus als fördermittelgeber und
wirklich auch als motor und antreiberin
für den natur und artenschutz
zudem und das ist vorher mir ein
bisschen zu kurz gekommen stellen wir
vier milliarden euro bereit für den
natürlichen klimaschutz womit wir
klimaschutz naturschutz und artenschutz
stärken und liebe unionsfraktion es hat
mich schon ein bisschen erstaunt dass
ihnen dazu nichts anderes einfällt als
wieder landwirtschaftliche betriebe
dagegen aufzuhetzen hören sie doch mal
endlich auf naturschutz und
landwirtschaft gegeneinander
auszuspielen ich glaube in diesem
aktionsprogramm natürlicher kinderschutz
liegt auch eine große chance für unsere
landwirtschaftlichen betriebe und
wir setzen wichtige akzente auch im
verbraucherschutz beispielsweise indem
wir die verbraucherzentralen weiter gut
unterstützen indem wir die
schuldnerberatung verstetigen und auch
das recht auf reparatur finanziell
unterlegen die bundesregierung zeigt
damit der bereich umwelt naturschutz
nukleare sicherheit und
verbraucherschutz ist ihr wichtig ist
ihr vor allem auch wichtig als
investition in die zukunft als
investition in die freiheit und in die
sicherheit kommen da generation
trotzdem darf die frage erlaubt sein
reicht das und mit blick aufs
internationale artensterben oder auch
mit blick auf die situation an der oder
glaube ich ist es wichtig dass wir da
noch mal nachsteuern
ich war vor ort an der oder ich hatte
noch tagelang diesen heftigen
verwesungsgeruch in der nase das ist
wirklich dramatisch und das sind zum
beispiel punkte internationale
biodiversitäts finanzierung und im
wahrsten sinne des wortes
wiederbelebungs programm für die oder wo
wir dann gerne noch mal miteinander
reden können ich bin gespannt auf die
beratung herzlichen dank freue mich auf
die weiteren diskussion
es folgt jetzt der abgeordnete klaus
mack für die cdu/csu-fraktion
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin liebe frau ministerin
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
unser ziel ist die bewahrung der
schöpfung das heißt dass schutz und der
erhalt und die wiederherstellung der
natur zum wohle der menschen in unserem
land aber auch zum wohle der
nachfolgenden generationen deshalb
führen wir die heutige debatte zur
einbringung des bundeshaushalts auch vor
dem hintergrund der ausgestaltung des
green deal der eu die europäische
kommission will die biologische vielfalt
fördern dazu schlägt sie
rechtsverbindliche ziele für die
wiederherstellung beschädigter
ökosysteme vor warum weil die bisherigen
empfehlungen nur zögerlich umgesetzt
wurden eine zentrale europaweite
regelung klingt da zunächst schlüssig
die bundesregierung sollte aber alles
daran setzen dass die zentralen vorgaben
aus brüssel subsidiär angelegt worden
die länder die kreise und die kommunen
müssen auf ihre verhältnisse vor ort
reagieren können und wir müssen in
deutschland aufpassen dass wir nicht
wieder in vorauseilendem gehorsam noch
springen und noch detailliertere
vorgaben machen vorgaben die am ende an
der lebenswirklichkeit der menschen
vorbei gehen gerade auch frau ministerin
beim aktionsprogramm natürliche
klimaschutz wir brauchen natur und
artenschutz mit gesunden
menschenverstand meine damen und herren
[Applaus]
und wir brauchen einen perspektivwechsel
in europa die eu will weg vom rein
defensiven schutz von biotopen und arten
hin zu einer offensiven naturnahen und
artenreichen gestaltung von lebensräumen
wir hier im deutschen bundestag hätten
einen solchen perspektivwechsel längst
vollziehen können und zwar bei der
verabschiedung der vierten änderung des
bundesnaturschutzgesetzes hier im juli
als es darum ging natur und artenschutz
mit den klimaschutzzielen unter einen
hut zu bringen die noch erneuerbaren
energien beschleunigt auszubauen leider
haben sie liebe koalitionäre der ampel
die chance verspielt die energiewende
umfassend zu denken die gesetzesnovelle
wurde mit heißer nadel gestrickt ihre
eigenen exporten im umweltausschuss
sprachen von einem
arbeitsbeschaffungsprogramm für
rechtsanwälte und wiesen auf erhebliche
rechtsunsicherheiten hin sie haben die
menschen vor ort mit unsinnigen
pauschalen vorgaben zur ausweisung von
windkraft lohan verprellt sie haben die
flexibilität vor ort wo hinter das ist
keine bürgernahe umwelt und klimapolitik
meine damen und herren das ist ein
durchregieren von berlin aus so nimmt
man die menschen vor ort nicht angst
ein punkt kriegen zumindest in die
richtige richtung die arten
hilfsprogramme legen den fokus nicht
mehr auf den schutz eines einzelnen
vogels es wird vielmehr der erhalt der
geschützten population insgesamt in den
blick genommen damit sollen mehr
windräder noch schneller gebaut worden
ob ihnen das angesichts des handwerklich
schlecht gemachten gesetzes allerdings
gelingt wird das jahr 2023 weisen am
ende wird es wohl viel wind um nichts
gewesen sein
dabei wäre es an der zeit diesen
perspektivwechsel im artenschutz auch
auf andere bereiche auszuweiten
solange wir aber eine eidechse vor 4000
euro pro stück umsiedeln die am ziel auf
kurze zeit später gar nicht mehr
vorhanden ist schütteln die menschen zu
recht den kopf oder die wiederansiedlung
des wolfes
zweifelsohne ein erfolg für den
artenschutz aber die akzeptanz findet
eben wenn die population nicht geregelt
wird ich sage dass insbesondere auch im
blick auf unsere weide tierhaltung sie
leisten mit ihren herden einen
wertvollen beitrag stadt defensiv in
kostspielige erstattungen für wolf
schäden zu investieren in diesem
haushalt sollten diese mittel besser
offensiv in die ausforschung der weide
tierhaltung angelegt werden gerade in
bezug auf den erhalt wertvoller
ökosysteme aber gemäß dem motto ein
schwarzes schaf findet sich immer
verschließen sie vor dieser realität
einfach die augen
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen der auch
volg aller maßnahmen im natur und
artenschutz und damit dem klimaschutz
steht und fällt aber natürlich auch mit
einem erfolgreichen vollzug dieser
programme beim naturschutz vor gab es
beispielsweise letztes jahr große
probleme mit der mit der verwendung der
bereitgestellten mittel auch dieses jahr
sieht es nicht viel besser aus wenn sie
aber das geld nur in irgendwelchen
haushaltsresten hin und herschieben ist
das wenig nachhaltig denn ein anderer
stelle könnten diese mittel durchaus
positiv ist wo unsere natur bewirken zum
beispiel beim programm zur
wiedervernetzung von lebensräumen für
das rotwild wildtier brücken können
nicht gebaut worden dass roth bild rot
genetisch zu verarmen nutzen sie doch
jetzt einfach die chance in den
haushaltsberatungen umzuschichten frau
ministerin die zahl der beamten stellen
hat sich beim bundesamt für naturschutz
mehr als verdreifacht allein mehr
personal und mehr geld zu bewilligen
machen aber eben noch kein erfolgsrezept
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen jeden tag
verschwinden auf der welt bis zu 150
tier und pflanzenarten der heutige
mensch ist also der natur weitaus
gefährlicher geworden als sie vor ihn
jemals waren wir alle also verantwortung
uns für die artenvielfalt einzusetzen
erfolgreicher natur und umweltschutz ist
aber nur mit den beteiligten möglich
doch wie die grünen sie rufen der grazer
laut bei der bürgerbeteiligung denken
das wissen wir ja der baden
württembergische ministerpräsident
winfried kretschmann sagte ma bei der
diskussion um einen nationalpark
es geht bei der bürgerbeteiligung um
gehört worden und nicht um eine politik
des aufhörens wenn wir die menschen aber
für eine nationale kraftanstrengung im
klima und umweltschutz gewinnen wollen
dann dürfen wir sie mit solchen aussagen
eben nicht vor den kopf stoßen meine
damen und herren
panta rhei alles fließt das wussten
schon die alten griechen wir wollen und
müssen also einen wichtigen beitrag zur
nachhaltigen entwicklung leisten das
bedeutet dass wir wegmüssen von starren
vergangenheitsbezogenen regulierungen
wir müssen eine moderne umweltpolitik
gestalten und zwar mit den menschen
vielen dank
als nächstes erhält das wort die
abgeordnete nadine heselhaus für die spd
fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin meine
damen und herren wie viel geld haben wir
eigentlich zur verfügung und wofür geben
wir es aus darum geht es grob gesagt in
unseren haushaltsberatungen genau diese
fragen stellen sich auch die menschen in
unserem land jeden tag und das aktuell
mehr denn je für viele ist die momentane
situation finanziell eine große
herausforderung
steigende preise in nahezu allen
bereichen bringen die privaten haushalte
in bedrängnis und zwar nicht nur die mit
kleinen sondern zunehmend auch die mit
mittleren einkommen
die verbraucherzentralen schlagen
deshalb alarm
denn an sie wenden sich die menschen
derzeit vermehrt
besonders angebote der energieberatung
stehen dabei hoch im kurs im haushalt
stärken wir deshalb den
verbraucherzentrale-bundesverband mit
der finanzierung zusätzlicher stellen
und das ist gut angelegtes geld
von wachsender nachfrage berichten
allerdings auch die
schuldnerberatungsstellen und das macht
mir noch größere sorgen umso wichtiger
ist es daher dass wir bereits im letzten
haushalt ein millionenbetrag zur
unterstützung der schuldner- und
insolvenzberatung in deutschland zur
verfügung gestellt haben und das führen
wir im nächsten haushalt sofort
noch lieber wäre es mir allerdings wenn
das gar nicht nötig wäre ziel unserer
politik ist deshalb dass menschen gar
nicht erst in eine situation geraten in
der ihnen überschuldung droht die
ergebnisse des koalitionsausschusses vom
wochenende gehen daher in die richtige
richtung denn das dritte entlastungs
paket enthält viele gute maßnahmen zb
zum beispiel die energiepreis pauschale
die wohngeldreform das neue bürgergeld
oder die mittel für ein bundesweit
gültiges
nahverkehrsticket ganz konkret helfen
werden den menschen auch die strompreis
bremse und dass wir strom und gas
sperren verhindern jetzt kommt es darauf
an diese punkte schnellstmöglich
umzusetzen
die vereinbarten entlastungen sind
zielgerichtet und das ist für uns als
spd und für mich persönlich zentralen
denn sie kommen in erster linie denen
zugute die dringend darauf angewiesen
sind transfer leistungsbezieher
rentnerinnen und rentner studierende
auszubildende
familien sowie menschen mit kleinen und
mittleren einkommen und damit
einmalzahlungen auch diejenigen
erreichen die bereits in den schulden so
geraten sind müssen wir klare regeln
dass sie unscheinbar sind weil es nicht
sein kann dass dieses geld am ende
inkassounternehmen zufließt
meine damen und herren wie ernst die
aktuelle lage ist zeigt sich auch daran
wie heißt zuletzt mögliche sparmaßnahmen
der privathaushalte öffentlich
diskutiert wurden dabei ging es vor
allem ums energiesparen befragungen
zeigen jedoch dass die verbraucherinnen
und verbraucher bereits generell ihr
konsumverhalten geändert haben und
zunehmend verzicht üben sie sparen an
lebensmitteln verzichten auf den
friseurbesuch oder schieben
anschaffungen hinaus und deshalb sind
die genannten entlastungen so wichtig
gut ist auch wenn wir uns weiter
aufmachen in richtung eines konsums der
gleichermaßen den geldbeutel und die
ressourcen schont aus diesem grund
bringen wir als koalition im herbst das
aktionsprogramm reparieren statt
wegwerfen auf den weg und stellen dafür
mittel in den haushalt ein damit es
einfacher und attraktiver wird das
smartphone oder den fernseher auch mal
reparieren zu lassen anstatt praktisch
nur auf den neukauf nur den neukauf als
option zu haben
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen gerade in
diesen zeiten brauchen wir eine aktive
verbraucherpolitik die die menschen ganz
gezielt anspricht formen der
aufsuchenden verbraucher arbeit müssen
wir deshalb unterstützen denn es gilt
das was bundeskanzler olaf scholz gesagt
hat wir dürfen und wir werden niemanden
allein lassen vielen dank
[Applaus]
jetzt folgt in der debatte jürgen braun
für die afg fraktion
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin meine sehr verehrten
damen und herren liebe kollegen
ich freue mich wir haben die lage die
kernenergie hat eine mehrheit in diesem
haus so wie es auch das deutsche
bevölkerung wir müssen das nur endlich
umsetzen das was wir als afg seit jahren
fordern dass es kern dieser debatte und
es gibt keine ausreden mehr es gibt
keine ausreden mehr wenn stromausfälle
passieren weil die kernenergie nicht in
gang gesetzt wurde meine damen und
herren es hat tradition grüne minister
reden nur ideologisch von umweltschutz
tun aber seit jahrzehnten nichts
sinnvolles für mensch und natur beim
verbraucherschutz ist es noch klarer die
verbraucher sind nur ein störendes
anhängsel im grünen ministerium kleine
etats werden winzig der stiftung
warentest soll das budget um die hälfte
gekürzt werden auf gerade mal eine halbe
million euro diese summe ist ein witz es
ist nicht viel mehr als ein rbb
intendant vom staat erhält
die stiftung warentest hat bisher nicht
nach biologisch grünen sondern nach
wissenschaftlichen und technischen
kriterien tests durchgeführt sie ist dem
ministerium ein dorn im auge und soll
bestraft werden bei der innovationen im
bereich verbraucherschutz sieht der
entwurf sogar eine kürzung der mittel um
mehr als die hälfte vor in diesem
ministerium ist für jeden ideologischen
firlefanz platz und geld
aber sobald es um verbraucherschutz geht
muss plötzlich gespart werden ebenso
interessant ist die wundersame
vermehrung der beamten des höheren
dienstes die der entwurf vorsieht zu den
behörden im geschäftsbereich des
ministeriums nun beim bundesamt für
naturschutz wollen sie mehr als eine
verdoppelung der b2 stellen zur
erinnerung b2 das heißt immer in fast
achteinhalb 1000 euro monatlich für das
umweltbundesamt verlangen sie mehr als
eine verdreifachung der b2 stellen und
beim bundesamt für strahlenschutz sollen
man höre und staune eine vereinfachung
der b einstellen auf einen schlag
stattfinden alles konsequent aus sicht
der ministerin lemke schon die zahl der
beamteten staatssekretäre hat sie
verdoppelt auch die qualifikation für
diese spitzenposition
staatssekretär sprechen bände da ist
einmal der politologe stephan thiel für
seine stelle insbesondere dadurch
qualifiziert dass er mal büroleiter von
jürgen trittin und claudia roth war und
da ist frau rohleder die über sexuellen
missbrauch promoviert hat das ist zwar
ein lieblingsthema der grünen aber es
hat weder mit umwelt noch mit
verbraucherschutz auch nur das geringste
zu tun man sieht an der personalpolitik
dieses ministeriums mal wieder die grüne
partei macht sich unseren staat
rücksichtslos zur beute und blechen
müssen dafür die bürger zum schutz vor
steigenden preisen zu nichts aber
zusätzlich zu spritpreis schock
strompreis schock und wieder gas umlage
wird der deutsche steuerzahler mitten in
dieser von ihnen verursachten krise auch
noch zur kasse gebeten um die grünen
genossen zu versorgen vielen dank
[Applaus]
als nächstes folgt die abgeordnete
doktor franziska kersten für die
spd-fraktion
[Applaus]
verehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
wir kommen aus der sommerpause zurück
neben ukraine krieg und krise haben wir
noch ganz andere probleme vor uns sie
haben alle bilder der oder gesehen wie
dort helfer hunderte tonnen von fisch
und anderen fisch lebewesen einsammeln
mussten das ist eine echte
klimakatastrophe oder eine echte
umweltkatastrophe und sie ist
menschengemacht
durch den von uns beschleunigten
klimawandel und den verantwortungslosen
umgang mit ressourcen haben wir es so
weit kommen lassen wir haben nicht nur
unwiderrufliche probleme in dem
ökosystem geschaffen sondern es kommen
auch soziale und ökonomische probleme
dazu und ich bin der krise noch sehr
dankbar wenn wir dann noch überreden
riva tatsächlich ob die
wiederherstellung des biotops oder und
auch die fischereibetriebe unterstützen
können
für mich zeigt das fischsterben anna
oder vier dinge erstens das thema
biodiversität bekommt immer noch nicht
genügend aufmerksamkeit dabei ist es
aber auf jeden fall untrennbar mit der
aufschaltung des klimawandels oder einer
gesunden umwelt verbunden was wir
brauchen uns eine naturschutz
beschleunigung deshalb stehen fast 49
millionen euro für das bundesprogramm
biologische vielfalt im haushaltsentwurf
zweitens wir müssen unseren
umweltbehörden investieren auch wenn das
fischsterben an der oder zum großen teil
ein versagen von seiten polnischen
behörden darstellt heißt es nicht dass
wir vor ähnlichen katastrophen gefeit
sind das fischsterben an der oder ist
vielleicht ein extremfall aber in
zukunft wird so was in zukunft häufiger
vorkommen können
wir wissen die ursache noch nicht aber
eine reduzierte
wenn sie dazwischen quatschen ich lasse
mich nicht gerne ablenken aber es ist
tatsächlich so dass die ursachen
begründung noch nicht da sie kommt im
september und durch ein verringertes
wasserangebot und ein wachstum von algen
die sozusagen toxische stoffe
ausgestoßen haben ist schon die ursache
menschen gemacht absolut schon
einzusehen dass es daran liegt gelegen
haben muss
es ist aber nicht nur wichtig
personalstellen verordnung haben sondern
wir brauchen einen durch die stark in
unserer behörden strukturen bessere
waren und meldelisten wir brauchen auch
auf bundesebene mehr leute denn wir
haben wirklich viel vor und wir wollen
naturschutz stärken und dazu brauchen
wir auch leute die sich dafür einsetzen
und die dementsprechend bezahlt werden
drittens wir müssen bei den zielen im
umweltschutz wirklich jetzt vollgas
geben allein für die im
koalitionsvertrag
verankerten neun themen wie das
aktionsprogramm natürlicher klimaschutz
die meeres offensive die norm
schutzstrategie die renaturierung von
ökosystemen die planungs beschleunigung
der den aus für den ausbau der
erneuerbaren brauchen wir personal und
finanzielle unterstützung
machen wir uns nichts vor wir hätten
jetzt schon bei einigen umsetzungs
zielen der europa europäischen
umweltgesetzgebung hinterher und müssen
nach steuern wie bei der umsetzung der
beauty
biodiversitäts richtigen die 20 30 der
wasserrahmenrichtlinie der nachschau und
des schutzgebiet managements und der
meeresschutz rahmenrichtlinie auch wird
eine verwehrt der überprüfung und
evaluierungen ist unseres
biodiversitätsverlust auf uns zukommen
am ende muss auch mehr geld in die
naturschutz forschung und eine
verbesserte datenlage investiert werden
vor der sommerpause haben wir hier im
bundestag den beschleunigten ausbau
erneuerbarer energien verhandelt
inklusive einer bundes naturschutz
novelle sie wurde er heute gelobt von
positionen immerhin als ausgleich für
nächsten windräder haben wir das alten
hilfsprogramm auf gesetzt dass die
möglichen verluste bei kollisionsgefahr
arten durch schutzmaßnahmen ausgleichen
soll es ist absolut wichtig dass das
auch funktioniert
nächstes jahr wird der bund 14 millionen
euro zum ausbau des programms beisteuern
die vorgesehenen bundesmittel in höhe
von 82 millionen bis 2026 sind
angesichts dieser bundesweiten
herausforderung auf land und see nur ein
tropfen auf dem heißen stein es müssen
den nächsten jahren mehr gelder frei
gemacht werden als jetzt vorgesehen der
vierte und letzte punkt für mich ist das
umweltprobleme grenzüberschreitende
probleme sind wir müssen in letzter
konsequenz über die nationale ebene der
gesetzgebung hinausgehen internationalen
hilfsprogramme fördern und auf eu ebene
auch in krisenfällen zusammenarbeiten
denn genau wie sich der klimawandel nur
schwer aufhalten das wird dieser
artenschwund nicht von alleine
verschwinden wir müssen dagegenhalten
für die oder gibt es wahrscheinlich
hoffnung auch wenn dieses wochenende
schon wieder frische tote fische
gefunden worden
experten haben über ein dutzend
verschiedener überleben der fischarten
gesetz gesichtet sorgen wir mit unserer
politik dafür dass solch ein
fischsterben nicht noch einmal passiert
franziska kersten war das hier für die
spd-fraktion zum einzelplan und umwelt
naturschutz nukleare sicherheit und
verbraucherschutz verbirgt sich auch in
diesem ressort pfeiler jetzt für die
union
präsidentin kolleginnen und kollegen
werden gäste auf den tribünen frau
ministerin lemke ich war ja wirklich ein
stück weit gespannt auf ihren ersten
wirklichen eigenen haushalt und beim
ersten blick darauf war ich auch ein
stück weit positiv überrascht beim
zweiten blick hat sich dann das bild ein
wenig eingetrübt und so einige
kritikpunkte haben wir auch eben schon
gehört
positiv anzumerken ist dass unser antrag
auf aufstockung der mittel aus dass für
den export von technologien gegen die
vermüllung der meere von dem du ja schon
gehört haben hier aufgegriffen wurden
wurde die mittel wurden von 17 millionen
um 8 millionen auf 25 millionen euro
erhöht obwohl die andere koalition das
im frühjahr bei den haushaltsberatungen
für den haushalt 2022 noch abgelehnt hat
jetzt ist es im haushaltsentwurf drin
das ist eine richtige und gute
entscheidung dank der sitzung ministerin
ansonsten meine damen und herren der
haushalt wächst um knapp 264 millionen
euro auf das klingt zunächst erstmal gut
aber jetzt ist natürlich fraglich ob
überall die richtigen prioritäten
gesetzt werden auch das haben wir schon
gehört da gibt es einige punkte auch in
meinen augen wo noch redebedarf besteht
und da müssen wir in den verhandlungen
noch mal ran eine frage die sich mir
stellt ist ob die mittel für den
natürlichen klimaschutz von dem sie auch
gesprochen haben 4 milliarden euro nicht
in diesem jahr wollen wir im nächsten
jahr sondern verteilt auf die folgejahre
und aus dem bundes naturschutz fonds nie
mittel zunächst erst mal um
26,6 millionen euro auf ob diese mittel
dann nachher auch tatsächlich in die
natur gebracht werden das müssen wir uns
natürlich anschauen denn die moden
ausgabe west reste genau im bundes
naturschutz fonds das sind in diesem
jahr 32 5 millionen euro meine damen und
herren es ist circa ein drittel des
gesamten etat ansatzes für 2022
das lässt denn doch schon bei mir
gewisse zweifel aufkommen ob dann dieses
geld tatsächlich auch ausgewirkt
ausgegeben werden kann
müssen die beteiligten die landbesitzer
die waldbesitzer die flächen nutzer mit
einbeziehen die müssen mitmachen und
daran hapert es in meinen augen landauf
landab und frau ministerin ich habe auch
stück weit meine zweifel ob sie es
schaffen diese beteiligten dann
letztendlich auch zu überzeugen gute
worte und hochglanzbroschüren reichen da
nicht aus wir werden also diese ausgaben
rest genau im auge behalten und die
effektiv der programme die sie noch
auflegen müssen dann auch entsprechend
begutachten zunächst erfreulich ist dass
andere auch schon gehört ist der
aufwuchs der mittel für den nationalen
meeresschutz auf 22 millionen euro davon
20 millionen euro für die bergung von
richtung von munitions altlasten
inklusive der verpflichtungsermächtigung
bis 2026 halte ich diesen mittelansatz
aber für zu gering und ich habe ja auch
schon gehört dass es da durchaus noch
gesprächsbedarf in den
haushaltsberatungen gibt diese mittel
dann auch entsprechend anzupassen
kampfmittel sind aber nicht nur eine
gefahr für mensch und umwelt im meer
sondern auch an land die kampfmittel
belastung allgemein ist eine ist ein
umweltrisiko
und hier finden verdachtsflächen in
wäldern heidelandschaften städten und
gemeinden und welche herausforderungen
daraus entstehen können meine damen und
herren konnten wir bei den waldbränden
in sachsen und brandenburg
[Musik]
vielerorts gerade im süden von
brandenburg und in sachsen konnten die
einsatzkräfte gar nicht auf die flächen
weil dort munitions lasten zu
explodieren drohten und so alleine schon
aus der luft möglich und das führt
natürlich dazu dass so ein waldbrand
auch nicht schnell in den griff zu
bekommen ist und bisher haben wir diese
kampfmittelbeseitigung immer unter dem
aspekt der gefahrenabwehr gesehen mit
hauptsächlicher zuständigkeit bei den
ländern ich halte das mittlerweile mit
blick auf die von mir geschilderten
herausforderungen für zu kurz gesprungen
bodenschutz meine damen und herren ist
klimaschutz und die ministerin ihr haus
hat eine frage von mir eingeräumt dass
diese gefährlichen altlasten
unsere böden und gewässer
beeinträchtigen können also
umweltbelastungen tatsächlich auch
darstellen und vitalität gemeinsam gut
daran alle gemeinsam die beamten
koalitionen werden wir zumindest die
diskussion führen würden ob analog zum
meeresschutz gemeinsam mit den ländern
der schutz unserer böden durch schnelles
und sicheres bergen dieser gefährlichen
altlasten aus dem
energie und klimafonds oder aus dem
paket den natürlichen klimaschutz nicht
anteilig mit finanziert werden sollte
auf planeten und herren ist es nicht
eine frage ob so eine munitions altlast
explodiert sondern die frage ist wann
sie explodiert und in meinen augen ist
schon gesagt sollten wir hier
gefahrenabwehr und umweltschutz
gemeinsam denken abschließend nur einige
sätze zur energiekrise als
verbraucherschutz sicht ist eine
effektive und schnelle entlastung der
bürgerinnen und bürger und natürlich
auch bei unternehmen notwendig das
angekündigte entlastungspaket von dem
wir heute auch schon gehört haben greift
hier zu kurz und kommt zu spät wir
müssen zwingen alle möglichen heimischen
energieträger zur energiegewinnung
einsetzen auch die drei noch laufenden
atomkraftwerke
und da wundert mich das schon sehr dass
gerade das atomkraftwerk in
niedersachsen ausgespart wird das hat
wahrscheinlich mit dem wahlkampf in
niedersachsen zu tun und dass wir geld
bereitstellen für die reserve aber dann
den strom tatsächlich nicht nutzen dass
es ein augen völlig verrannt hier ist
die bundesregierung gefordert und habe
auch nicht schuldig sind aber zum
schluss präsidentin von der
verbraucherschutzministerin erwarte ich
eine abkehr von ideologischen denken hin
zum pragmatischen handeln ich freue mich
auf die anstehenden beratungen
vielen dank
da sagt feiler hier für die
cdu/csu-fraktion und wir haben hier noch
einen redner der sozusagen das letzte
wort nicht nur zu diesem einzelplan hat
sondern auch zu diesem ersten tag der
haushaltsberatungen und das ist reiner
johannes keller für die
spd-minister liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen ja keine frage dieser sommer
war bietet schon richtig knackig und er
war zu heiß wir haben es alle
erfahrungen wir kunden seine spüren und
nach veröffentlichten daten des
deutschen wetterdienstes gab es über 800
sonnenstunden in diesem jahr ist neuer
rekord
die größte anzahl von sonnenstunden seit
der wetteraufzeichnung
was jetzt für einen sonnen liebenden
menschen eine große herausforderung
beziehungsweise eine große freude war es
für unsere gesamte gesellschaft eine
große herausforderung
denn es ist nie einfach nicht weg zu
diskutieren
die menschen gemachten
klimaveränderungen spüren wir nun alle
hitzerekorde
trockenheit starkregen ereignisse werden
wir auch in den kommenden jahren immer
wieder und immer mehr erleben und daran
müssen wir uns anpassen denn das was wir
jetzt haben werden wir auch behalten
und dieser großen
gesamtgesellschaftlichen aufgabe werden
was das ampelkoalition stellen und wir
werden diese herausforderungen auch
annehmen
wir werden die klimaanpassung in
deutschland entschieden voranbringen und
dafür wie im koalitionsvertrag
vereinbart ein starkes fundament
schaffen
die begonnenen finanzierungsgespräche
mit den bundesländern werden hoffentlich
bald zur handfesten ergebnissen finden
und für mich und meine fraktion ist
dabei klar hier muss geklotzt werden und
nicht gekleckert
denn die volkswirtschaftlichen schäden
ohne klimaanpassung werden um später
teuer zu stehen kommen
mit den dann zur verfügung stehenden
mitteln müssen wir zügig in die
umsetzung gehen die klima an
veränderungen die wir jetzt alle schon
erleben werden nämlich nicht wahr
das zeigt mehr als deutlich die wir
stark religion ausgelösten
flutkatastrophe im sommer des
vergangenen jahres
und um auf solche ereignisse
einschließlich ihrer verheerenden folgen
besser vorbereitet zu sein müssen wir
die gesamten gefahrenkarten weiter
standardisieren und überregional
zusammenfassen kann sich gar nicht
vorstellen was für ein sammelsurium
passen ist ebenso brauchen wir für die
zukunft ein gebündeltes
informationsangebot aus dem sich alle
zuständigen stellen bedienen können das
aktuelle nebeneinander von verschiedenen
informationsplattformen den tritt in den
kommenden jahren nicht weiterbringen
und auch unsere flüsse zeigen in diesem
jahr mehr als deutlich was passieren
wird wenn wir nichts tun
überall trockenheit landauf landab fisch
werden und das betrifft nicht nur die
oder wie konzentriere seine nordtiroler
ich in meinem wahlkreis habe ich einen
kleinen nebenfluss der lenz ist da waren
in dieser woche über um das helferinnen
und helfer ehrenamtlich um fische zu
halten das ist eine auswirkung des
klimawandels
das kann man auch nicht mehr
wegdiskutieren
großen dank übrigens an die helferinnen
und helfer die das ehrenamtlich hier
gemacht haben ich denke dann das haus
aufpassen
[Applaus]
was jetzt überall trocken landauf landab
fisch der geschädigte ökosysteme
eingeschränkte transportwege und
zerstörte infrastruktur das sind die
folgen wie sagt tödliche cocktail aus
niedrig was auch mohn temperaturen und
schädlichen menschlichen einträgen eben
auch in die oder das sind aber nur die
traurige spitze dieses eisbergs um
unsere schlüsse besser von den
klimaveränderungen zu schützen brauchen
wir mehr renaturierten morgen und damit
halten wir wasser aus dem winter länger
in der landschaft und die flüsse können
sich daraus speisen
doch gerade bei mauern programm von
ministerin müssen wir glaube ich noch
ein bisschen nachlegen denn in den
kommenden jahren müssen wir deutlich
mehr tempo machen und damit wir unseren
zielsetzungen erreichen ja der vorschlag
präsidentin mich jetzt hier gleich weg
patch das letzten redner ich muss ein
satz noch loswerden der sei mir
gestattet weil bislang habe ich nämlich
den eindruck dass wir dort noch ganz
ganz viel luft nach oben haben und auch
viele verbände sehen das so und das
sollten wir dann eben auch noch mit in
unsere haushaltsplanung berücksichtigen
wir sozialdemokratinnen und
sozialdemokraten sehen dazu bereitet
konstruktiven dialog zu suchen und ich
denke dass ich jetzt mal langsam zum
ende kommen
[Gelächter]